The connection between logic and
human cognition is interesting.
Logic is a very important school of
thought in AI, for several reasons.
One reason is that logic provides a very
formal and precise way of reasoning.
Another reason is that logic provides
a formal notation for expressing how
intelligent agents reason, whether or
not they're using logical reasoning.
But does this mean that logic
is also the basis of cognition?
It suddenly appears that humans
use logic some of the time.
For example,
I may have a statement like if I get
a big bonus, I'll take a long vacation.
I did get a big bonus, therefore I
may infer I'll take a long vacation.
This is clearly.
But simply because of a behavior appears
to be logical, does not necessarily
imply that we use logic as
a fundamental reasoning strategy.
I might solve a new problem, by analogy
to a previously encountered problem,
I did not use logic, but
my behavior appears to be logical.
The logic that we have considered so
far is deductive logic.
But a lot of human reasoning is
inductive or abductive in its character.
If you haven't come across
an abductive so far,
we will discuss in detail
later in the class.
Deduction has to do with
reasonings from causes to effects.
Abduction has to do with
reasoning from effects to causes.
When you go to a doctor,
you go with some signs and symptoms.
Those are the effects.
The doctor comes up with
a disease category.
That's the cause.
Abduction is reasoning from
data to an explanation
to a disease category for the data.
Induction is given some relationship
between cause and effect for a sample.
How do we generalize it between
a cause and effect relationship for
a population?
So while human reasoning appears to be
inductive and abductive in character
much of the time, the logic that we
have considered so far is deductive.
That's yet another issue that we'll
return to later in the class.